I want you all to be bons okay Bon is a
girl's name you need to shut the
up yeah let's
go do itn't keep uh Aaron have you
seen Michael
oh hey there you
are take that you should see their
baby so I guess you recognize everybody
else you all right she's
[Laughter]
drunk wow
rain rain what
sorry wow you coming
rain oh whoa whoa
oh Ellie I think we're out of fact cover
sheets
who shut it okay wait there it is uh it
is rumored that they will declare I
can't I can't see
it you don't know your
L I lost bankruptcy what are you talking
about yeah I'm happy because if Jim and
Pam
can't
yeah I'm thrilled because if Jim and Pam
can't be Employee of the Month nobody
can that's real
fair oh that's the greatest thing I've
ever seen I just got out of the restroom
and it stinks the warehouse needs to go
okay wait how do you know it's the
warehouse who stunk up the bathroom
because they stink up the
bathroom no okay wait how do you know
it's a warehouse worker that's dunk up
the bathroom they stink up the bathroom
with their smelly poos Jenna they're
going to turn on us come
on I can't
talk just let him flirt with her people
meet each other all sorts of way who are
we to stand in the way bam you know he's
not going to get anywhere and you know
he's going to blow our sail who cares
it's not that huge a sail the
schwap BAM you know he's not going to
get anywhere and you know he's going to
blow our sale who cares it's not that
huge a sale the Schwab guy do
us that's okay
random want to take care of this invoice
okay copies and triplicate right back to
Mr Bernard
[Music]
dog okay you know what I would want you
to get tired walking around all
day
let me give it a whirl here no I really
want to I'll talk I want to do it it's
okay hello well that's great paper was
there all
along you're really too tired to do this
me too then let's just not do it do you
have any idea the risk involed sorry you
did that was
fny I'm sorry I just made me laugh I
never understood that corporate
mess well okay David W likewise
I'm
not I'm not David
Wallace I might be someday David Wallace
likewise
black
[Laughter]
okay Alper cram it in there
all right
guys now I know what you're thinking
won't that just shed more light on the
penises but you know what that's is a
risk we have
to that
is that is a risk that we have to no no
no I know what you're saying why you
keep
going hey I know what you're thinking
won't that just
shed I know what you're thinking won't
that just shed more light on the penises
but that is a risk we need to take Pam
thank you Pam why don't you work with
Bas and draw a picture of the
exposer I want it on my desk by the end
of the day or you will receive a full
disadulation what's
that I love the way John cracks do we
have any
muffins
yeah take a longer pause before you
answer Pam Jimbo last chance to
carpool s you want a
carpool car poool yep little car pool
together we're going separately s h
what little car pool together
yeah I'm going seam
no carpo will carpol together
yeah I'll meet you
there hello Michael how are you good how
are you good to see sorry
there okay well why don't we just step
in what
hey
I want to give you a nappy head because
you're
lesli well that's not your
character doy yeah could you write down
the name of that Rehabilitation Clinic
you men
W press that's great
what does that even
say will the someone's fault well no
it's it's not it's not anybody's fault
you know what let's just look at the
lines and then we'll do the scene
[Laughter]
again
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'm sorry bye
Stanley what did you call
me come on Phyllis come on oh Jesus
you're all right Phyllis are you all
right are you okay I'm okay and this
copier
is working fine that's the original
[Laughter]
well could not have made a better
noise hey
[Music]
wa the mall is corrupt mall is evil
they're appearances
okay Jim that is so
inappropriate oh I should get the
accident report binder I've never used
that gun F form before what what say
what you're trying to say we can't
understand you ever we can never what
did you just say Toby Toby get back in
here right now I should go get the
action report F
because to's having having
a she go
hospital great group back there too uh
Holly and um
Mindy could think of her name but it's
played by Mindy the actors you will
learn to be more
[Laughter]
profal
hey
hey D Jesus
stop you're all coming to my show
tonight right we're still going who
cares
Andy that was that was
mean
I like that I can sit on your lap now
you can sit on my lap all you want
because I am a male Santa and that is
something that Phyllis cannot do oh my
God okay this is really
comfortable okay tell me what you want
little
boy I don't know I didn't know you were
going to ask me that what did you think
was going to happen I didn't know no
one's ever let me sit on their lap
before hurry up just say some
toys
can can you give me some choices oh my
God Kevin please
sorry Coppa squat here we
go
sorry COA squat I'm glad what would you
like for Christmas little
Kevin I don't
know I didn't know you were going to ask
me that well what did you think was
going to happen
here sorry
all right
here